bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de l'avenir de la téléphonie mobile avec
le samsung galaxy 10 alors samsung
galaxy 10 galaxie x je sais pas vraiment
comment le prononce si on le prend comme
apple c'est le dise si on le prend comme
samsung bas ça peut être le dise ça peut
être le x on n'en sait absolument rien
ce qu'on sait en tout cas c'est qu'il
s'agit d'un modèle qui devrait être
révolutionnaire on commence en parlait
depuis 2011
l'idée est tout simplement génial on l'a
vu dans les films dans la science
fiction dans harry potter
l'idée d'abord des écrans qui se plie et
qu'on peut utiliser sur ses smartphones
sur ses tablettes
certains en ont rêvé a priori samsung
serait sur le point de le faire et ça
c'est juste révolutionnaire on va parler
dans cette vidéo de ce que devrait être
ce samsung galaxy x on va l'appeler
comme ça en tout cas pour le moment ce
qu'il devrait apporter les
caractéristiques techniques
qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir en faire et
qu est-ce qu on entraperçoit dans tout
ça est que à la fin on fera un petit
débrief vous me direz ce que vous en
pensez vous mettrez des jolies
commentaires des jolies pouzout vous
abonner on s'aime c'est l'amour tout ça
tout ça tout ça quoi bref comme je vous
le dis c'est une vieille histoire une
histoire qui remonte à 2011 où samsung
avait annoncé par son service de
recherche et développement qu'ils
avaient réussi à créer un écran
complètement pliable et qu'ils allaient
en sortir un smartphone très rapidement
bon le très rapidement a mis un peu plus
de temps que prévu a priori
sept ans après samsung devrait faire
deux annonces majeures au premier
trimestre 2010 8 une hausse et es à las
vegas au mois de janvier et une autre
lors d'une présentation officielle au
mois de mars alors en règle générale au
mois de mars
ils présentent leur flagship l'année
dernière on a eu le s uite suite plus
cette année je sais pas trop comment ça
va s'organiser
samsung pourrait présenter au cs sont s9
et s9 plus et réserver la primeur du
galaxy 10 pour sa présentation du mois
de mars
c'est un produit qui au début ne
pourraient sortir 4 quelques exemplaires
alors quand je dis quelques exemplaires
ce n'est pas des millions d'exemplaires
on parle pas non plus de 2000 3000
exemplaires a priori tablerait aux
alentours des 100 mille exemplaires cent
mille exemplaires qui serait peut-être
distribué uniquement en corée du sud
pour samsung
c'est un peu la main mise sur un marché
qui connaît parfaitement bien ce qui est
sûr en revanche c'est que ce produit est
ce que coûtait que tout de suite un
petit peu cher alors forcément il ya des
années de recherche et développement
c'est une nouvelle technologie des
brevets il va falloir l'amortir dont
forcément dans tout ça le prix va être
tirée vers le haut quand on voit déjà le
prix du samsung galaxy note 8 qui a
passé les 1000 euros
on imagine très bien sur un produit
novateur avec un écran pliable
on va forcément tout de suite dépassé
les 1000 milles 5 peut-être même de 1000
euros bon alors ça c'est de la
spéculation on a absolument aucune
information sur le prix aujourd'hui mais
ce qui est sûr c'est que c'est un
produit qui va pas être cadeau à quoi
devrait ressembler ce produit alors il
ya eu des spéculations folle on a
imaginé une espèce de nintendo de ds
qu'on pouvait ouvrir avec un grand écran
à l'intérieur ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il
ya eu des brevets déposés par samsung
donc les brevets ne manquent pas il ya
un brevet qui fait état de a priori deux
écrans qui seraient très proches et
qu'on pourrait effectivement bien ouvrir
soit un peu à l'horizontale comme une
nintendo ds qu'on pourrait complètement
retourné pour avoir les écrans ben comme
un espèce de bord à bord recto verso on
a aussi des représentations qui nous
ferait état d'un smartphone un peu comme
dans les années 2000 vous savez comme
les samsung à l'époque où les motorola à
clapet qu'on ouvre est confirmée avec un
seul et grand écrans à l'intérieur
alors la question qui se pose c'est
avoir un grand écran pliable why not
effectivement mais ce qu'il faut
forcément une structure pour le
maintenir pour le maintenir en place
parce que si vous avez juste un écran
il faut forcément un processeur derrière
il faut forcément stocker une batterie
donc aujourd'hui tout n'est pas assez
miniaturisés pour qu'on puisse avoir une
espèce d'écran qu'on manipule sans autre
protection sans autre coq sur votre
structure
il paraît assez évident qu'au jour
d'aujourd'hui avec les technologies
qu'on a on va avoir un écran on va avoir
une structure alors appris comment
est-ce que ça va se présenter en clape
et comme l'est d'ailleurs ça ça fait un
peu canard comme je fais comme ça en
clape et comme les motorola de l'époque
où comme les samsung de l'époque
dès les années 2000 comme une dîme tendo
de ds à la verticale ou à l'horizontale
ça on sait pas encore la seule chose
dont on est sûr c'est que samsung va pas
vous faire un espèce de modèles avec un
gros boîtier moche et puis un bel écran
milieu
le to va être intégrée pour ça
corresponde à une nouvelle norme ce
qu'ils jouent aujourd'hui c'est l'avenir
de la téléphonie mobile samsung innove
avec des écrans on imagine très bien
qu'ils vont pas sortir une structure
toute moche qui ressemblera des produits
il ya vingt ans donc voilà ça c'est plat
dessus il faut pas trois comme on est
aujourd'hui sur quelque chose qui
n'existe pas on peut effectivement on a
tout imaginé du meilleur et du pire
les quelques informations qu'on a de
certaines c'est une certification
bluetooth 4.2 et qui est paru au mois de
juillet de l'année dernière sous le
numéro smg 8 8 8 f zero c'est un numéro
qui effectivement un peu barbare
derrière on pense que c'est ce samsung
galaxy 10 mai ce qui pose question c'est
le bluetooth 4 points 2 pourquoi aller
mettre un mot tous 4.2 alors
qu'aujourd'hui la norme est ce qu'on
retrouve d'ailleurs son flagship de
samsung c'est un bluetooth 5.0 ça n'a
pas trop de sens de la côte et pourquoi
est ce que samsung irait faire
accréditer un modèle bluetooth 4 points
2 alors que le note 8 et tous les autres
produits qui sort chez samsung sont déjà
en 5.0 ça ça pose question
idem il a été certifié par la wifi
alliance
donc on va très bien qu'à des choses qui
se passe du côté de chez samsung sur un
produit qui va arriver d'ailleurs il ya
peu de temps sur le site de samsung le
galaxy 10 a fait son apparition avant de
disparaître très rapidement il est temps
d'être repéré par quelques curieux et
quelques malins d'ailleurs qu'au de
linky un haut responsable de chez
samsung a effectivement lui aussi
confirmé qu'en 2018 le samsung 10 le
samsung x devrait arriver dès lors
qu'ils ont réussi à résoudre toutes les
problématiques que toutes les
contraintes techniques liées à cet
appareil
autre chose qui est surprenante on va
trouver un androïde 6.0.1 marshmallow
aujourd'hui on est passé au 8.0 oreo on
était jusqu'à il n'y a pas longtemps aux
sept points pour un nougat pourquoi est
peut-être tout simplement parce
qu'effectivement on va être sur un
marché un petit peu serré sur des
versions test alors il ya une rumeur qui
dirait qu a priori ça me saoule
sortirait ce galaxy x dans un premier
temps en corée et qui prit ensuite son
hôte neuf avec cette technologie
donc pour l'instant effectivement c'est
un peu le bazar la seule chose qui
vraiment vraiment vraiment sûr c'est
qu'on n'a jamais été aussi près de la
sortie du samsung galaxy 10 d'ailleurs
il paraîtrait qu'un prototype du galaxy
dix ont été présentés
une poignée d'industriels au wmc l'année
dernière à barcelone mais ça dans le
plus grand secret aucune information de
la fuite et si ce n'est cette
présentation au final qu'est ce que ça
va changer d'avoir ce nouveau smartphone
parce que si on peut pas aller acheter
s'ils coûtent très cher qu est ce que ça
va changer pour nous dans nos vies alors
rassurez vous ça va changer beaucoup de
choses comme toutes les nouvelles
technologies qui arrive au début elles
sont très chères elles sont dans les
smartphones dans les technologies
premium ensuite elle arrive dans les
technologies je dirais moyen de gamme
puis ensuite dans les entrées de gamme
est ce que ça se passe de toute façon au
début les produits sont réservés à une
élite avec des grandes dit mais ceux qui
ont les moyens d'aligner les billets
ensuite pour la masse pour le
consommateur lambda et puis ensuite
voilà une nouvelle salle georges comme
ça alors ça présage un avenir très
intéressant et des technologie hyper
intéressante on peut imaginer d'avoir
effectivement ma des bijoux connectés on
a déjà des montres connectés aujourd'hui
mais on s'en fout effectivement avec un
petit cadran on pourrait très bien avoir
tout un bracelet avec un écran tout
autour avec différentes informations
on peut très bien imaginer des bijoux
des bijoux où vous auriez tout un motif
qui pourrait changer tous les jours en
fonction de l'humeur en fonction de la
saison et en fonction des normes et
moins de choses pourquoi pas avoir un
bijou qui est connecté sur une expo
d'art vous allez à l'expo est bien votre
bijou change
au lieu d'acheter un bijou vous pourriez
juste acheté le motif vous dire bien
tiens ce tableau là je les trouvais
génial ou cette création de tels
artistes pour tel bijou est génial je
vais acheter la création je ne sais pas
quels artistes en vogue qui va aller
avec mon bijou c'est tous des choses
qu'on peut imaginer du vêtement
connectés aujourd'hui on va avoir des
écrans pliables pourquoi pas l'intégrer
demain aux habits conecteo qui a
énormément de possibilités et ce qu'on
entrevoit ici c'est vraiment l'avenir du
rapport entre l'homme et les écrans
l'homme et les objets connectés et ça
c'est passionnant voilà aujourd'hui ce
que je peux vous dire sur ce futur
samsung galaxy x galaxie 10 dites moi ce
que vous en pensez
est ce que c'est quelque chose que vous
surveillez est ce que c'est un produit
qui vous intéressent
est ce que ça vous paraît trop futuriste
déconnante oui non est-ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'on va trop loin pas
assez vite passé loin mark et moi tout
sans commentaire parce que c'est super
intéressant et c'est vraiment quelque
chose de passionnant
je vous invite à laisser un joli pousse
à vous abonner à la chaîne passera
toujours toujours et
plus de contenu pour parler de high tech
de californie de smartphones totalise
aussi de sa du afrique bref merci à vous
de regarder la vidéo je vous dis à très
bientôt soyez sages portez vous bien et
d'ici là
gros bisous ciao
[Musique]